[Music]
John Sheridan is one of 30,000 people
who cross the border between the
Republic of Ireland and Northern Ireland
every day for this farmer whose fields
lie on either side of the border the
concern is very strong couldn't be
possible
you can't one side is going to be in
Europe and the other side's not simple
as that so how is it gonna work I as far
as I'm concerned at Camp workman the
border stretches 500 kilometers across
Ireland with twice as many border
crossings as the entirety of the EU
eastern frontier on one side Northern
Ireland is part of the United Kingdom in
the south is the Republic of Ireland for
30 years this border was the subject of
a bloody conflict between pro British
loyalists and pro Irish Republicans
result three and a half thousand dead
until the 1998 peace agreement beyond
the economic consequences people on the
island also fear a return of tensions
between the two communities our mirin
fairs of breaks it is it seen a hard
bargain again after 20 years we do not
want to see this we have a good fried
agreement as Brian 20 years go on
everyone is welcome to that the peace
remains fragile the last watch tower on
the border was dismantled in 2007 peace
walls still separate Catholic and
Protestant communities in Belfast
Parliament's brexit coordinator Guy
Verhofstadt
is committed to doing everything
possible to avoid a hard border what we
never will allow there is that Ireland
will suffer by the British decision to
leave the European Union that's a
commitment that we have taken with the
European Parliament and it's a
commitment also that has been taken by
the whole European Union as a whole
a resolution has already been approved
in the European Parliament pledging to
preserve peace and limit the effects of
break sit on the island of Ireland
[Music]